welcome to this video playing just one
guitar one of my regular opponents here
playing quite often maybe go for a Slav
or okay get a Slav plate them okay in
the chobani ankle with a six a couple of
times but after quincy 286 isn't such a
great idea okay let's play and solid
fashion with g6 it's not not bad I
wonder about c5 here I think this was
played against me recently and they
didn't really know how to how to handle
that this is of course a bit like the
goon felt with Quincy to work on as an
extra move the question is if that
really is is something or something that
white can exploit he takes on c5 I
probably take on c4 and play Queen a 5
or queen f5 instantly yeah why not why
not actually Queen a for something I can
play Quincy five and I'm threatening 94
the typical groom fraud stuff tour takes
nite nite d5 also looks like decent
position
in the in the goon felt um proper
there's the Queen on d1 still and white
is playing um I think I think captures
you or not on d5 I don't know if latter
no really but okay in this position
Queen a for Quincy five looks looks
decent and what is he doing actually
taking on d 595 looks okay yeah and now
i can i can just take or Quincy five
even why not taking 95 look so nice
pinning him here this it seems like I'm
having the Queen on c1 c2 is actually
two blacks advantage and he's burning
lots of time hard to imagine that
someone's actually spending more time
than I do but he does yeah I just taking
him I can just take it oh come on upon
us upon if he wants to have it back
quickly he needs to go night a for which
isn't the greatest movie ever our
greatest looking at least just hear him
to have the queendom on a safe spot
okay if it takes what the bishop had
looks it looks we Adam I always have
Bishop d7 and rook c8 stuff like that
attacking the night Bishop c4 I even
have b5 and its really embarrassing and
the Queen takes I don't know okay so he
wants to take on c4 with the night hmm I
don't be five is playing a show f3m well
this looks arm looks interesting
hmm so we should give a go Boop to d7 I
can take the seven and take with the
Queen probably it's not great for white
but it's a playable nights you for
always okay this is easy i mean at least
i've added it speeds up my development
light back on c3 i play em maybe this
isn't so bad even at c3 now that i think
about it i still cannot play before this
was interesting maybe yeah here I
thought them it's a it's simply a good
good development for me so no particular
problems but it's also not especially
great night 25 may be attacking f4
contending night to be six or something
attacking be two at the end it's so
quite often a good idea to go wait
what's this if I take take f4
let's grab a phone easy easy easy to
play now and I just get me to at the end
it's am probably probably not especially
great exchanging the a four-night
doesn't look like the greatest
achievement devil came but still it's
it's decent it's not bad for me
one difference is the pawn structure if
I get a night on b6 or d 4 or something
like that then a night Bishop Bishop on
d4 of course then known this always
attacks f2 well he cannot attack f7 is
there some way to to set this up Luke c7
first yeah okay let's just just play
that it's a solid and good don't need to
rush things here yeah looks it too
coming
yeah this is a slightly slightly
annoying position for white rook see one
ok I want to be to be safe on the back
rank as well and don't do the exchange
so how to improve let's do this and then
see how to improve f2 adds probably
still very dry
you
o Queen six you could have played
Queenie six want to get the bishop on c5
playing very slowly though I'm warning
yet so it's mentioned very dry check
check check game drunk oh that just took
their 31 ah oui okay yeah I spent far
too much time as usual I know I need to
be a bit more precise here that I can
maybe do a bit here it's very dry of
course yeah but so it feels like with
very precise play there should be
something Brooksie one maybe I don't
know
yeah I mean I didn't didn't have any
problems out of the opening this was was
an interesting idea Bishop f5 computer
gifts yeah this is good to really like
Bishop f5 didn't think about it at all I
mean this is solid and cynical and quite
easy to play but not the the best move
problem yeah interesting and quite a
close finish at the end okay thanks for
watching